and the previous episode of Walking Dead
are now you bet
why did you buy delay no oh come on turn
to God
whatever series have to find okay it's
now or never I didn't know anything
yeah I feel like a got time that son of
a [ __ ] who wouldn't come with us they
[ __ ] us
what hey you got Bauer he didn't have
plenty should have left your ass
Crawford top [ __ ] you Kenny
[ __ ] you Kenny yeah you know how they
died
you said goodbye I never got to see my
family my parents my little sister so
give me a [ __ ] break
why should he come down in the house oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] the gun man
[Music]
how's it going red
welcome back that said - good - Bharat
whoa really good job Ben
excuse me Ben but what are you good at
everything later everyone okay
we still bitten [ __ ] you can't okay
let's get out of here and keep moving
kids right we got to keep moving
I think there's any chance we get Clem
and catch up to those goddamn thieves I
don't know maybe we're we're not going
out through this window
no latches no roof access and 30 feet
straight to shed anyone have any ideas
now that this guy would he's got a
resourceful air about him knock it off
Dixon Kenneth I made Krista just trying
to lighten the [ __ ] tone we need
solutions not stupid jokes I come on my
lying in your piss a I'm sorry all right
so there's got to be another way
there's got to be another way check the
floor for any other access event
anything or we wait for the house to
clear out and stick to the high ground
he will be dead before that Olli you
okay yeah yeah
just leave what the [ __ ]
please Abby Lee society Lisa Sammy what
what the hell we get up fight for time
there yeah do it for climate what did
that mean she's at the hotel where a
parent was we know it she is man he
hasn't moved her yet yeah yet we need to
start thinking about more than just
Clementine when it comes to our urgency
what do you mean how do we get out of
here [ __ ] that's the whole yeah we're
fine we don't know okay now your life
depends on it
how do you get out of here I don't know
I don't get it I do okay what is it how
long do you think we have what I don't
know we should have made you take it off
well you did and it's too late now
O'Shea I think we need to have an adult
conversation about what happens if Lee
takes another spill Hey look we could be
looking at a Larry situation here who's
Larry hey don't matter he looks fine to
me you wanted yeah okay what do you want
to do just talk about is that
conversation in with me kidding
something dropped on my head now hey
guys
I don't know what happened before Omid
and I showed up but we can cross this
bridge when we get to it
Lee I'm not advocating anything here but
how is this not a thing
we're all so worked up about Clementine
that we're forgetting what the [ __ ]
happened to you Miami's not damaged my
arm is not the issue I'm not the problem
the 500 walkers in the house and no door
in this room are the goddamn problem
yeah maybe at the moment but who's to
say when it becomes an issue at that
point there may not be any time left to
deal
this is getting out of hand Kenny
they're gonna listen to me we will get
Clementine back with or without you
because I haven't given up everything to
die tell me mother stupid to kill me you
son of a [ __ ] okay
don't even [ __ ] hesitate I will [ __ ]
you Kenny
how did not huh well that way better
than expected face oh shut up sweetie
there's a fake room it's corroded to
hell it's disco Rhoda what's on the
other side of this wall a 30-foot drop
No
this mansion butts up against the one
next door that's awesome the swirling
[ __ ] is this really possible did
something useful Kenny you [ __ ]
[ __ ] drunk tired yeah we can do this
okay we'll work in shifts everything
goes to hell every time you wanna get
ready we have to work fast I wasn't
gonna hurt you
I wasn't gonna hurt sure pal I know what
the [ __ ] Kenny mighty gotta be an
[ __ ] sometimes I don't know why I'm
glad you told us when you got bitten
I'd have been easy not to yeah I
probably would have let you go alone if
you hadn't told us which would have been
a mistake if I were you I would have
been scared shitless
I am I
and when it happened feel it inside me
the day before you get the flu wish you
would have taken it off don't think it
matters much now I'm losing a lot of
feeling it's really tingly like it's
asleep
that's disgusting
let me get this guy what do you think we
make sure he never does it again make
sure you never roads do you think I
should have cut the bone off because I
talked to some other people and they're
like we cut the bone now and I'm like
seriously can we not talk like I'd like
you leave said it doesn't matter now I
don't the entire time we were at the
hospital playing it this way thank you
I'm not gonna make any adjustment in
this later to know it we all know that's
a wrap
there's gotta be something I want you
guys to take care of her I want you guys
to take her stop it I'm serious
she'd be safe and relatively relatively
we're not doing this right now why not
we have to do it come on it's what I
want okay there's a dying man well we
got a support on we he's only a kid
still it's easy to forget that yeah you
lose his [ __ ] like that often no that
was a first
it's good Betty hey Kenny couldn't pull
that [ __ ] on me
triple on well it seems like it got
through to Kenny that's good for all
right I'm out of gas
you look good and rested sure if you
don't count an infected leg you want me
to do it no and you can hop in after me
come on that was only a couple minutes
[ __ ] [ __ ] shouldn't be long now
that's good we're forced to take a
breath I still can't believe you went
and got chomped just so we get a chance
to connect these he told us took some
brass I don't think I would have what
how are you
I'm I don't know how to answer that I'm
sorry
you've lost more than anyone
well beer I can well as much as anyone
it'll be all beer I can why are you
acting like what's happening happened
anyway I appreciate it from both you a
lot of us have lost families
maybe take it easy on him for an hour I
am angry as hell yeah thought his fault
maybe maybe you heard about something I
did I never really thought about it that
way
spanner Kenny you're improving huh
some wine that's a good idea whiskey I
think this guy tell you much about what
we've been through
bits and pieces see that lump on his
face you did that Maya hey Dan what I'm
there in the rainbow water under the
bridge all we can do is move forward
well Cheers
no she's not gonna take it come on Chris
now you're better than that
no I would the [ __ ] man she really
wanted a drink huh yeah I'm through does
he keep that mustache in trim that for
so many days no Walker's things are
looking up
shoot the one with a gun go first
they're so unorganized it bothers me
everyone keep a goddamn eye out how they
come from there is there another hole oh
well this place seems pretty sealed off
well
ah man that's scar what the bar what
that bomb
that's disgusting no that's horrible she
shut the wafers and then shot himself
might have been the right choice more
leave all the people we've seen go they
got to do it their own way together
don't you say that you stick it out as
long as you can you do whatever you have
to I could have done more you did
everything you could man you did
everything
stay strong brother no only yeah tell me
I could have been a better husband now
come on get better father could have
been a better friend so let's figure out
a way out of here get that little girl
we should move yeah got at least one
shot left Lee figure out where we're
headed Lee you okay I'm fine yeah let's
keep at all right every [ __ ] thing
all right
so find a way out has anyone thought
about this door no only me we got to be
on the high up all right we could jump
over there put so far between or some
[ __ ] nothing other than personal items
in here Kenny looks like we can stay off
the streets all the way to River Street
if we're careful let's jump between the
building go ahead what do I have you
been
careful now lay ah damn he's good at
that he's really good at that
that is [ __ ] smiles
man I would have been so scared to have
someone that matters to me with me on a
thing like this
no [ __ ] Ben it's not gonna make a bet
he's not gonna make it
bet he's not gonna make it I saved you
your ass man you bet
[Music]
with me and my [ __ ] mouth
holy [ __ ] is he dad we're gonna do what
Kenny ah Kenan I got in and I can handle
this dude let me help you you're already
hurt even more reason we all don't need
to risk it you worried about her yeah
that's right look at for your girl she's
tall for him what the five becoming
turns lasts all day man well keeping
stop talking like it's a bear we thank
you
he's got to be die if you hit your head
there was blood I saw blood right away
oh oh you piss a come on I'm okay Shh
why did we talk about Ben I'm okay just
get me out of here quiet beer will be on
top of us
yeah try to keep your mouth shut and
it's gonna dies get me up my legs man
it's gonna die I know it I know it I
know it
Ben it's gonna get your ass tonight
really I thought your son the Sammy's
gonna come he got this thing through him
son of a [ __ ] what I ain't looking good
[ __ ] hell he's gonna give the last
bullet to Ben what is it I'm okay I'm
okay
we could get you up we can oh I don't do
that
Yankee mom just yank him off that day
what fast like a bad day do you think we
want to play [ __ ] given the ball
Oh God don't let them get to me too late
for that then
have any bullets left says only got one
left in it I'm out [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here
what go back Shinichi Lee surely this is
not a discussion
hello hell no man
I'm not leaving it I just say let's get
bin and get out of here fine [ __ ] Kenny
Lee Lee is OK
Oh kid oh it's not it's just something I
gotta crack Yuma you know Maddie - that
girl tried the weirdest moments back you
sons of [ __ ]
[Applause]
jesus [ __ ] christ man [ __ ] try
what happened you should have [ __ ]
sent up the band in my opinion but I'm
happy happy can finally came to his
senses and did what was right I mean
they're gone
yeah God I heard a shot can it took Ben
out Kenny made sure that bid didn't feel
any more pain and he had to what it was
bids biggest fear you know Kenny had one
bulletin that's how he used it yeah poor
[ __ ] kid
you saw them die nobody was getting out
of there I'm sorry Lee [ __ ]
mosquitoes man [ __ ] mosquitoes it
wasn't a bad guy a lot of folks might
not have always agreed maybe even me
we should go right behind you
alright alright Prez hope you enjoyed
this episode like a beard if you did
subscribe to cut my breath today and
I'll see you in tomorrow's episode I'll
be breast
you